we all will get away and the celebs just seemed to do it right so I headed to secrets part though Los Cabos Golf & Spa Resort in Mexico to find out how to do it how to vacation like a star from the moment we arrived my wife and S&I were treated like a listers at the adults-only resort on the Sea of Cortez check out these coastline views you can see three miles of the ocean the resort has two pools the infinity pool was my personal favorite the lounge chairs right in the water overlooked the golf course nothing says vacation like a swim up bar and a cocktail what an incredible getaway I mean I loved it and coming up all this week on a tee more of my amazing vacation tomorrow Vanessa and I hit the spa you